bonjour nous sommes le vendredi 19
février bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal de fin de
semaine voici les principaux titres de
cette prochaine demi heure dans le
quartier des sablons à plaisir un
nouveau centre commercial à voir le jour
openskies c'est son nom a été présenté
jeudi soir aux habitants dans le cadre
de la semaine de l'emploi à saint
quentin en yvelines un focus vient
d'être fait sur les métiers du futur
nous verrons ce que propose l'estaca
école d'ingénieurs basée à montigny le
bretonneux et comme chaque vendredi
retour également sur les faits
importants de l'actualité depuis le
début de la semaine lancement de la
campagne des jo-2000 24 à paris chantier
de rénovation de l'hôpital charcot à
plaisir et présentation de la ligne 18
du grand paris aux élus locaux
le nouveau centre commercial opensky à
plaisir va enfin sortir de terre les
travaux doivent commencer cette année
l'ouverture est espérée pour 2018 fin
2018 il le prendra place sur l'ancienne
galerie des sablons laissé quasiment à
l'abandon depuis une décennie les
habitants ont découvert les contours de
ce projet lors d'une réunion jeudi soir
michael almy devant plus de 500
personnes dans la salle du théâtre
espace coluche de plaisir jeudi soir 18
février pour la présentation du futur
centre commercial
openskies ce projet structurant pour la
ville attendu depuis dix ans pour
remplacer la zone en friche de la
galerie des sablons suscite à la fois
inquiétude et espoir
je suis venu en fin de compte à la
réunion de ce soir par rapport aux
quartiers par rapport aux problèmes qui
actuellement et par rapport à l'école
par rapport aux problèmes qui va y avoir
parce que l'école juste à côté des
travaux
je pense que ça peut créer de l'emploi
ça peut résoudre certains problèmes
comme l'accès à la gare pendant la nuit
ce genre de choses la rénovation de la
place du commerce et de la venue des
sablons qui va en découler par la mairie
est très important pour les habitants
après on espère vraiment que ça réglera
aussi les problèmes de sécurité du
quartier dont on se bat depuis plusieurs
années depuis plusieurs années le
problème de drogue ce genre de choses
une structure d'autant plus attendu par
les plaisirs oies qui vaut dans ce futur
centre commercial de 32 mille mètres
carrés la possibilité de retourner au
cinéma elle va accueillir en plus des 35
mr ces six restaurants un multiplexe
d'une dizaine de salles c'est un projet
sur lequel nous travaillons depuis
plusieurs années qui est un projet qui
n'est pas uniquement un espace culture
pas culturelle si culture est justement
mais en tout cas pas uniquement
commercial parce que c'est un projet de
lieu de vie le chantier de l'open sky
est confiée à la compagnie phalsbourg gh
choisi selon le maire de plaisir pour
être réputé avant gardiste dans la mise
en place de lieux de vie pourquoi est-ce
que ça a marché c'est très simple vous
avez constaté les énormes travaux sur la
rd 30
nous sommes à l'entrée de la zone
commerciale de plaisir c'est le meilleur
emplacement nous sommes face au chant il
y aura un rond point qui va être créé
avec les deux nous allons avoir des
super en scène larchitecture va être
belle et on travaille pour nos clients
donc on va tout faire pour qu'ils
adorent cet endroit
les travaux de l'open sky devrait
démarrer d'ici trois mois une maquette
du chantier sera présenté aux plaisirs
oies en juin prochain
livraison du centre commercial prévu
pour 2018
la semaine de l'emploi se termine à
saint quentin en yvelines et parmi les
rendez vous proposés à un zoom sur les
métiers de l'industrie du futur c'était
à montigny le bretonneux dans les locaux
de l'estaca nous y avons assisté nous
sommes allés également la rencontre des
différents enseignants pour mieux
comprendre ce que seront les emplois de
demain fanny bordjiens le numérique a
déjà révolutionné notre quotidien mais
comment les formations s'adapte t elle à
cette évolution
c'est la question posée au campus de
l'estaca lors d'un forum des métiers du
futur
aujourd'hui les employeurs recherchent
des salariés de plus en plus compétents
le numérique
de toute façon on ne peut plus passer à
côté c'est à dire que les gens
aujourd'hui sont habitués à travailler
avec le numérique avec les médias
sociaux donc il va falloir l'intégrer
dans l'industrie du futur on aura besoin
de profils un petit peu plus polyvalent
aussi c'est des métiers qui sont
vraiment en évolution et qui sont de
plus en plus demandés dans l'entreprise
des secteurs du numérique en pleine
mutation imprimante 3d objets
intelligents réalité augmentée autant
d'opportunités qui attire de plus en
plus d'étudiants de perspectives
d'évolution fond mon sens on sont
vraiment intéressants tout le monde on
touche du doigt une révolution quand
même sur ce point ça fait ça fait
toujours plaisir en tant qu'ingénieur si
je peut élargir mon champ de compétence
et l'intérêt faire du numérique ça ça
m'intéresse énormément
ce qui est important c'est de voir ce
que cette projection parce qu'en fait on
sait dans quel secteur on va travailler
ce qui nous intéresse à savoir à quoi
ressemblera notre métier plus tard à
l'estac à l'école d'ingénieurs implantée
à montigny le bretonneux les étudiants
se forment aux métiers du futur
ici ils suivent un cours de technologie
automobile ou leurs compétences pourront
leur permettre d'imagés les voitures de
demain sur la voiture autonome la
technique existe et que c'est
complètement
digéré qu'on a tout un tas de
partenariat avec des start up ou des
grands constructeurs des équipementiers
pour savoir où on en est le deuxième
point qui va falloir lancer ça va être
de savoir à quoi ça sert on voit la
france et des grandes réflexions sur qui
payent qui va gagner de l'argent avec
comment un qui ça va servir en premier
comment ça va rentrer quelles vont être
les premiers véhicules les premiers
utilisateurs dans le futur les véhicules
autonomes auront un impact fort sur
l'emploi des transports au total ce sont
3 millions d'emplois de tous secteurs
confondus qui pourraient être détruits
par la numérisation d'ici 2025
d'où l'importance de réadapter les
formations du secteur industriel la
suite de votre édition du vendredi de ce
journal la direction présents versailles
et le tribunal administratif qui couvre
les départements des yvelines et de
l'essonne nous avons rencontré la
présidente de la cour d'appel qui tenait
à l'audience solennelle de rentrée au
début de la semaine nous avons fait avec
elle un point sur l'activité des
magistrats qui y siègent écoutez nous
sommes donc avec le président de la cour
administrative d'appel de versailles
conseiller d'état bonsoir martin de
modèle commence à vous êtes en poste
depuis le 15 juillet 2010 et vous aider
à tenir cette audience solennelle au
tribunal administratif est ici donc à
versailles il a été question tout à
l'heure notamment de l'état d'urgence
jeu j'aimerais que vous nous rappeler ce
que c'est quelle incidence ça peut avoir
sur votre activité aussi cet état
d'urgence et notamment sur les
assignations à résidence parce que vous
êtes sollicités pour alors en ce qui
concerne de l'état d'urgence c'est
surtout le tribunal administratif si
j'ose dire qui est en première ligne
dans le cadre justement de demandes de
suspension et
et sur le fondement du référé liberté de
suspension de ces mesures qui sont
prises par les préfets
donc en première ligne on en premier
temps c'est le tribunal administratif
mais comme je lé indiqué bien souvent
les personnes concernées ne font pas que
demander la suspension en urgence de la
mesure elle n'a conteste sur le fond et
elles peuvent aussi essayé de rechercher
la responsabilité de l'état pour avoir
pris cette mesure si cette mesure est
déclaré illégal et c'est donc en appel
devant la cour que peuvent venir les
contestations des jugements rendus et je
crois si vous voulez savoir qu'un
certain nombre de tribunaux
administratifs du retard on tue donc non
seulement des contestations l'urgence
mais aussi des contestations sur le fond
qu'ils vont les juger ils ont commencé à
le faire par exemple à cergy pontoise
évidemment nous allons avoir des appels
que nous essaierons de juger oui nous
aussi dans des délais adapté c'est à
dire qu'on ne peut pas laisser ce show
et ces choses dormir si j'ose dire trop
longtemps lui soit pas durer pendant un
an on se prendra bien sûr c'était un
impératif fort de quelques quelques
précisions sur votre activité c'est
l'occasion aussi de le faire d'activités
peut-être aussi méconnu du grand public
alors il ya eu une cour administrative
en france l'émission ce sont c'est tout
simplement de statuer sur les appels qui
ont été formés contre les jugements des
tribunaux administratifs
quelles sont les affaires qui reviennent
tout simplement le plus souvent pour
vous car durée premier contentieux le
contentieux des étrangers
donc le contentieux des titres de séjour
des obligations qui était un territoire
deuxième contentieux plus spécifique le
contentieux fiscal spécifique sur
l'administratif d'appel de versailles en
raison de la présence dans le ressort du
tribunal administratif de montreuil
parce que vous avez en seine saint denis
je m'y attarde un instant des très
grandes directions fiscales comme par
exemple la direction générale des
grandes entreprises qui est le guichet
fiscal unique pour toutes les
entreprises tout au moins 400 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires 3ème
contentieux la fonction publique
et puis
urbanisme vous savez la contestation
donc de permis de construire par exemple
des bureaux
et puis également le travail avec les
plans de sauvegarde de l'emploi très
important aussi attendre une forte
hausse sur l'année 2016
c'est en haut c'est exactement de 74 et
2008 76 60 oui alors là ce contentieux
du travail la ce c'est moi les plans de
sauvegarde de l'emploi que le
licenciement de salariés protégés
ce qui montre quand même aussi que ce
contentieux reflète la réalité de notre
territoire du point de vue économique
une forte hausse de l'activité
globalement de votre activité
nous avons effectivement en 2015 une
hausse de 10 % qui s'explique surtout
par la bouche de contentieux des
étrangers et de la fonction publique
quels sont les autres dossiers vous
pouvez être amené à traiter y en a qui
sont plus spécifiques que d'autres qui
sont peut-être plus difficiles aussi je
pense au projet de construction d'une
mosquée par exemple sur la ville d'
sûrement que la ville ça a été forcément
très médiatisée c'est un peu plus
difficile de statuer sur ce genre de
dossier
c'est à dire c'est d'autant plus
difficile que c'est un juge qui ça tout
seul c'était nous étions saisie dans un
cadre très particulier ne devrions pas
avoir mais nous étions saisie en appel
d'un référé je devrais dire d'un référé
suspension qui avait été introduit par
le préfet des yvelines est donc là mais
le juge a examiné effectivement s'il y
avait ou non un doute sérieux et il a
considéré qu'il y avait un doute sérieux
et puis d'autres affaires intéressant
peut-être aussi qu'ils peuvent parler je
crois au grand public
c'est tout ce qui concerne l'urbanisme
commercial savez nous avons autorisé par
exemple l'implantation de costco qui est
une de ses très grandes surfaces qui
vous permet d'accéder vous savez à des à
des prix qui défient toute concurrence
mais pour acheter des produits également
si choisir qui défient toute concurrence
en commun quantité c'est à dire qu'au
lieu d'acheter votre petit pot de
nutella
vous avez fait 5 kg de nutella d'un
poumon et bien au vu de tous les
argument qui nous était présentée nous
avons considéré que l'autorisation qui
avait été accordé à costco était valide
était légale sur les différents dossiers
que vous traitez on parlait de cette
hausse pour l'année 2015 est ce qu'en
ça prend le même chemin qu'ils allaient
avoir il est trop tôt pour le dire nous
savons simplement là les chiffres de
janvier donc il est vraiment trop tôt
pour le dire
ensuite nous verrons non absolument pas
pour avoir une idée véritablement de la
hausse il faut avoir au moins les les
données du premier trimestre sinon du
premier cela sur le dos les traitements
ont parlé d'une amélioration sur l'année
dernière ce qui est plutôt bon signe
on imagine les gens veulent des
décisions rapides exactement oui
effectivement si vous voulez nous avons
raccourci nos délais de jugement nous
l'avions déjà fait en 2014 nous avons
poursuivi en 2015 s'ils voulaient pour
essayer de parler clair en ce qui
concerne notre stock nous sommes
capables compte tenu de notre puissance
et loisirs de jugement de l'éliminer en
un peu plus de 9 mois est le délai moyen
moyen évidemment c'est une moyenne mais
de jugement ou des affaires de
l'ensemble des affaires qui sont devant
la cour c'est un fait c'est un peu plus
de 11 mois donc c'est inférieur à un nom
alors cela mêle des affaires contre est
très vite parfois en un mois ou en
quelques jours
depuis d'autres affaires qui prennent
plus de temps parce qu'il peut y avoir
sur certains contentieux nécessité de
poursuivre et de prolonger l'instruction
pour que véritablement tous les moyens
tous les arguments pour être puisse être
échangé
question par les delà de la hausse de
l'activité est ce que ça va de pair avec
une hausse de moyens nous avons deux des
moyens qui nous ont permis de faire face
à la hausse de l'activité puisque jeux
de vancouver ne tenterait par neuf
sorties et j'espère que nous allons
continuer l'année 2016 également
j'espère que de l'eau continue à baisser
c'est vous qui vous occupe beaucoup en
ce début d'année 2016 en ce début
d'année 2016 non c'est que nous avons
aussi nous avons eu de très gros
dossiers fiscaux que nous allons bientôt
lire et est notifiée suivez les c'est de
très très gros en dieu merci beaucoup
merci seconde partie de ce journal et
nous passons à l'essentiel de la semaine
le zapping de l'info locale depuis lundi
la semaine de l'emploi se poursuit à
saint quentin en yvelines ce matin à
guyancourt l' agence pôle emploi cadres
a réalisé un job dating en partenariat
avec quatre autres agences de la
communauté d'agglomération une centaine
de candidats se sont présentés
ils ont tous été préalablement
sélectionnés par les conseillers pôle
emploi depuis 10 ans déjà l'association
expo france 2025 travail sur sa
candidature si son coût s'élève à près
de 25 millions d'euros les retombées
économiques devraient aller au delà des
23 milliards
un événement d'ampleur qui attire entre
50 et 60 millions de touristes pas de
constructions hors norme pour cette
édition mais un village global installé
au coeur du grand paris voulu par les
responsables du dossier des jeux
olympiques de 2024 ont présenté
aujourd'hui à la philharmonie de paris
les contours du projet parisien parmi
les sites retenus quatre sont dans les
yvelines les épreuves de cyclisme sur
route passeront par la vallée de
chevreuse et saint quentin en yvelines
les épreuves le château de versailles et
va accueillir les épreuves équestres et
le pentathlon le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines basée à
montigny le bretonneux organisera les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et de bmx
donc ce serait vraiment un coin bien le
voudront prouver
ça permettrait de continuer dans le
projet de développement du cyclisme à
voir tout ça à proximité ce serait se
serait très nettement la ligne 18 qui
reliera orly et versailles chantiers et
sur les rails les responsables de la
société du grand paris ont visité
aujourd'hui les points stratégiques du
futur tracé de 35 km dans les yvelines
deux gars vont être créés à guyancourt
la structure sont implantés dans le
quartier villars ouah je pense que c'est
très important les entreprises en parle
c'est une perspective
elles ont besoin de savoir que leurs
collaborateurs pourront facilement se
déplacer
et c'est pareil pour les habitants
depuis le début de l'année la ligne
express 67 a été améliorée elle relie
houdan à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
avec désormais un bus toutes les heures
dans les deux sens aux heures de pointe
comme aux heures creuses
le dossier était dans les cartons depuis
près trois ans des fresques géantes
devront être dessinés sur les façades
des bâtiments dans le quartier du vélib
ou à plaisir une réunion publique était
programmée ce mercredi soir à la
mosaïque pour lancer le projet de
présenter aux plaisirs oit les soldes se
terminent ce mardi 16 février
versez de bilan est mitigé les commerces
ont connu pour cette période d'hiver une
fréquentation meilleure que celle de
2015 et une hausse du chiffre d'affaires
est estimé entre 1,5 et 3 % au niveau
national à wang chen paris la tendance
est aussi ressentie surtout le début de
la période certains commerces ont
enregistré une progression de 45 % de
leurs ventes
on a beaucoup de gens qui ont des
trésorerie négative et qui peine de plus
en plus à s'en sortir sur leur
exploitation
selon un rapport de l'institut de veille
sanitaire paru en 2013 environ 500
agriculteurs se sont donné la mort entre
2007 et 2009
prochainement la fédération des yvelines
du parti communiste français organisera
des ventes directes avec des exploitants
à peine âgée de quelques jours et déjà
debout cet agneau ne le sait pas mais il
fait partie d'une grande lignée de
moutons il est le descendant des mérinos
espagnols arrivés à rambouillet en 1786
une race devenue unique au monde
arias officiellement lancé sa
candidature pour recevoir les jeux
olympiques en 2024 et vous derrière ce
dossier allez-vous soutenir la france de
réponse avec ce micro-trottoir signé
jacques de dixmude ça va ajouter de leur
poche france pendant les jeux donc on va
pouvoir conçu des nymphes est sûr aussi
c'est pas mal donc
puis ça va communier faire en sorte que
le peu plus communier tous ensemble
c'est très bonne chose ça peut apporter
un peu de dynamisme quelques dans la
région au mois dans la région c'est pas
sur toute la france je veux olympique
situent leurs quelque chose de
sympathique
c'est important pour nous pour tout le
monde pour la communauté création d
emplois et autres c'est super important
assurait que l'on espère depuis un
moment qui qui est qui et c'est les jo
chez nous après donc c'est bien voilà ce
que j'avais c'est très intéressant pour
la france et après plusieurs échecs ce
serait bien qu'on gagne enfin quoi c'est
magnifique ça eu tout ça c'est génial
pour tous les jeunes et pour tous les
pays surtout que cette année se met au
brésil c'est magnifique du 6 avril
brésilien se contente je souhaite la
même chance pour la france bien sûr
ce sont à présent les jeunes qui
s'expriment sur l'actualité locale
nationale comment ont-ils perçu
l'information ces derniers jours c'est
qu'on se préparer avec les élèves du
collège des soldes guyancourt
c'est une compétition mondiale qui
regroupe toutes les
quasiment toutes les catégories de
sports c'est en fait quand on quand on
fait des compétitions de sport et que
allah frein bayadh et là des gens
sportif qui monte sur le podium et ils
ont gagné des médailles
plusieurs épreuves leur exemple la halle
classicisme la judma succès et c'est une
histoire quoi je m'en a parlé des
anciens jeux olympiques qui s'était pour
les dieux ça permettait de le
représenter
the kills et d une compétition par
exemple la lutte et à la fin et recevez
une une palme en lauriers je sais qu'il
y en a eu à vancouver et partout
ailleurs mais pas vraiment ici pour moi
je trouve que c'est une bonne idée que
bas que le département il s'associe à te
connaître paris aussi ça nous permettra
peut-être déjà 2
mettre en avant notre pays ça me mettait
les siens peu qu'ils appellent des jeux
olympiques à paris pas qu'à paris comme
la capitale de la france donc voir s'il
y avait les optiques je pense que j'irai
les voir forcément parce que si c'est
juste à côté c'est pas donné à tout le
monde dit alex change un peu de
territoire pendant ça va ça voyage quoi
je trouve ça bien
globalement je verra un peu toutes les
commissions kia parce qu'il y en a
vraiment qui sont enfin que je trouve
extraordinaire j'ai pas le lancer de
poids par exemple les choses comme ça où
les personnes font vraiment des trucs
incroyables se retrouve à la 3e 4e place
on peut déjà être très sûr de soi même
s'il n'a pas gagné une coupe et c'est
tara va déjà rien d'avoir participé je
trouve ça courageux dans la mesure où on
peut gagner c'est vraiment bien mais je
trouve que ces mails participer même si
on est sur des potes seront motivés ont
dit bon je vais le faire quand même quoi
c'est pour le fun quand le fait surtout
module programmes de radio sensations à
présent nos confrères qui vous propose
ce week end 1 m dos politique avec
véronique côté millard mer des
clayes-sous-bois vice-présidente de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines conseillère
régionale d'ile-de-france elle évoquera
avec nicolas kirillovitch l'actualité de
sa commune et sont arrivés dans cette
nouvelle agglomération
écoutez cet extrait elle parle de ses
différents mandats avoir plusieurs
mandats c'est intéressant parce que
c'est vrai qu'en tant que maire ça part
et ça paraît inconcevable et vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure que les maires ne
représentent pas leur commune au sein
d'une intercommunalité
je pense que c'est quand même là les
fans les plus à même les deux de le
faire et ensuite au niveau de la région
j'étais donc je voudrais très investis
j'étais longtemps vice présidente au
sein de du coup de paris métropole
donc ça m'a donné ça m'a donné déjà à
l'envi donc de continuer à m'investir
pour les régions île de france et j'ai
la chance de code coup de connaître un
certain nombre d'élus toutes tendances
politiques confondues sur la sur la
région ile de france
donc c'est pas quelque chose non plus
que j'allais dire c'est pas complètement
nouveau pour moi donc c'est pas
totalement une découverte les sujets de
la région ile-de-france l'actualité
locale revient sur notre antenne lundi
en direct à 18h première diffusion 19
heures et aussitôt replay sur notre site
internet voici quelques-uns des sujets
qui seront développés l'ubs et risation
de l'économie tout d'abord est elle une
chance ou une menace pour la société
c'est la question posée par jean
frédéric poisson député des yvelines
président du parti chrétien démocrate il
vient d'organiser un colloque à paris à
l'assemblée
là sur cette question il est également
candidat aux primaires à droite et au
centre météo france fête ses 120 ans à
trappes dossier sur le centre
météorologique à découvrir dès lundi en
deux volets nous en apprendrons plus sur
son fondateur et vous verrez les outils
qui sont encore utilisés sur place et
puis le salon de l'agriculture ouvre le
week-end prochain en plein milieu des
vacances à la fin des vacances scolaires
porte de versailles à paris les yvelines
seront comme d'habitude bien représenté
le point sur les agriculteurs et les
producteurs présents dans quelques
instants juste après ce journal ces
forains à manille pour le 7-8 week end
avec les
des sorties loisirs pour les prochains
jours et peut-être rire et vous au
cinéma pour découvrir la vache c'est
l'histoire d'un paysan algérien qui rêve
justement de participer à ce salon de
l'agriculture qui va ouvrir un film avec
notamment le trappistes l'yvelinois
jamel debbouze
on se quitte donc avec la bande annonce
à lundi pour le journal cher monsieur
bel abbès comme tous les ans vous avez
fait une demande de participation au
salon de l'agriculture est mythomane
laquelle il la direction du sang dans
alice et du coup vous invitez vous elle
vous accueille
on retient mars et tu appelles montrera
portant son beau frère
non non non mais t'as pas cher qu'on se
régale en contact avec des sacoches
regarde moi ça vaut des listes noires
des cauchemars vous savez écrire oui on
détache et ma chérie à n'ont pas mâché
ses mots si ma femme n'a honte quand
même
il s'appelle à face à bel abbès et
depuis plus d'un jour il traverse la
france écoutez bien pied
on ne voit que me faut graver passe
intelligente est devenu une star
je me sens donc
un toast à l'eau avant le début du
concours il ne pourra y participer sur
le périphérique à sa bouche un peu leur
retard des caisses conçues pour les
jeunes
comme on dit on peut voyager loin et
lâché des voitures